comme on est dans une télé réalité
au confessionnal actuellement mais on
n'est pas censé savoir ce qu'elle dit
valérie bénard et j'en peux plus de
julien parce que ben je sais pas mais
julien il est tout le temps derrière moi
il me colle il me colle
en plus il est lourd il est regard dans
sa façon grave et un train déjà tf1 ils
essaient de me choper mais bon il était
jeune et beau fallait il a pris quelques
années quand même le gars est là il est
tout le temps là je sais pas si vous
avez vu mais il a essayé de m'embrasser
après il vient de voir une colle la main
aux fesses il fait ça lui poule est très
amis la série je pourrais me dire à
présenter à ma mère cyril c'est mieux
quand même que julien ce que je n'étais
pas présente et julien courbet à ma mère
enfin alors que là il est enfin pas prêt
avec sa petite chemise comme ça on
dirait un matador tu vois il est comme
ça quelle bonne idée ce ton pc par
rapport au confessionnal écoutons les
confessions de miguel de rennes elle est
pénible à isabelle elle n'arrête pas de
me mettre des mains au cul cantonnés
dans les loges le côté cougar c'est pas
trop mon truc mais je crois que en plus
une petite ouverture avec la petite
portugaise
apparemment ils ont tous essayé de la
pécho ils sont tous près des pirates au
doigt je pense que je vais lui faire ma
brandade spéciale avec chorizo incorporé
que ça pourrait lui la pétillante je
sens que ça peut marcher pour moi j'ai
une ouverture et s'il faut coucher bah
oui je suis prêt à coucher surtout avec
elle mais mes voeux n'est pas pour
occuper
président ou non est ce que j'ai de
poils n'ont pas de ça alors ça ne fait
pas plaisir ou stigmatisés et thierry
moreau voudrais faire une confession
alors ça y est j'ai une certitude c'est
que je pense que valérie à coucher pour
être là parce qu'elle est quand même là
tous les jours pendant la semaine c'est
avec cyril le vendredi c'est avec julien
elle a couché je vous dis que ça plaît à
tout le monde se pose la question
pourquoi je fais un chèque à bertrand
chat mort à tous les soirs parce qu'en
fait je veux pas l'embarrasser parce
qu'il a une haleine de chacun peut faire
juste lui faire un petit chèque comme ça
voilà on se rapproche pas trop comme ça
je suis tranquille j'ai jamais vu un
truc comme ça parce que quand même tous
les matins sur rtl il fait croire qu'on
est grand copain 1 et les transitions ça
se passe toujours super bien et là quand
j'entends ce qu'il dit souvent qu est ce
qu il a dit tu t'es vu quand t'as bu
non mais moi je vais le faire trinquer
je fais tout toute seule du sol au
plafond moi avec mes petites mains tout
à la main mon cousin lui il a converti
il paraît il paraît il paraît qu'il se
passe des trucs des fois le soir avec
les assistants moi je suis pas là pour
le voir
jusqu'à quand même trop de gens qui le
disent pour qu ils pas de fumée sans feu
alors moi un jour patrick le lay disait
on m'a pour mis à prix nobel j'ai vu le
prix j'ai pas bu le nobel bas je pense
que des villes
gare à lui c'est un chacun le sien ce
bertrand je me réveillais l'embrasser
pour la faire taire